hey guys how's it going happy vlogmas
day 8 you guys don't know what vlogmas
is it's vlog every day until Christmas
I'm probably just gonna vlog all of
December unless I don't know promises I
like to just promise a little bit and
then be an overachiever instead of
disappointing you know it's it's it's
rough tech Tuesday because I never on a
Tuesday who knows it actually will be on
a Tuesday because I have a special
episode for you guys tomorrow anyway I'm
going to a shoot with Evelina I'm so
excited because I absolutely love her
she's so sweet and I haven't seen her in
a while and yeah it's early it's still
dark it's 6:30
got up at 4:30 let's safe to say I'm a
little tired but I've got coffee so
don't worry then are you really worried
so we're on our way to Palm Springs and
I'm kind of losing my mind because I've
never seen a Starbucks like this before
there's a drive-through
and then it's like a walk up Starbucks
like I I have never seen anything like
this in my life
Evelina I am freaking out about the
Starbucks if you seen anything like this
before
hey I can't get over this it's like a
this little mini Starbucks gonna take a
peek inside
it's free that's really great it's a
great idea I'm gonna brush my hair a
little bit here what not to do a little
brushing of the hair
ace
I'm signing
been here for a while I can't believe
I'm at the eighth
I see pitar checking in here all the
time but I read your home yep yeah they
make memes of him sometimes the pitar
memes he's got a ball saved on his phone
he loves them guys look at this cookie
sandwich ice cream you should eat it
smells look at our contrast Hills good I
just said pancakes so that's true we we
we had it we had a real meal listen
sorry sir thank you female we had such a
fun day shooting today I could not have
asked to have a better first time in
Palm Springs the setting with Evelina we
did so much stuff and don't tell me
about the show that's coming out there's
no episodes out yet right no not yet I
think the first episode is gonna be
December 10 so on Wednesday basically to
travel show I have a fun guest every
time it's gonna be on the refinery29
channel so thank you so much for being
here I am so excited she is amazing no
you're losing weight oh my gosh it is a
Trevor Trevor oh it's so pretty
this is also so exciting Evelina just
launched a jewelry line tell us about it
please look what you're wearing it yes
it's one of my pieces is like a sleek
unicorn it's like it has like geometric
angles and everything's very sleek and
simple and sort of geometric and weird
and yeah it's so awesome and you know
you'll probably see it on Instagram too
because when people
thank you
not really just using the internet
internet yes yeah yeah pretty pretty
pretty addresses cool addresses
oh yeah connecting stops yeah do that
grab you might are you so shitty